dragon ball twitter is the [ __ ] i
every time i see every time i see a
shitty take starting off strong
like you just see the dumbest [ __ ]
take it's always from a [ __ ] dragon
ball
yeah or like someone who like just
tweets about dragon ball
yeah because i i remember seeing like so
many shitty tweaks like i remember
seeing this one
one tweet that was like talking about
like how like vegeta was like the
greatest anti-hero ever written in anime
or something like that
that was like the common thread was like
more hilarious than the take itself and
i think my favorite meme
was just like goku going super saiyan
and he was just like
at the top text was like don't [ __ ] with
dragon ball fans and the bottom text was
we only know one anime
it's true though what is it about dragon
ball fans that
only watch dragon ball like everything
they consume it's like
it's like you know they're a dragon ball
fan when they're like
but gt wasn't that bad was it
like did you see the tweet that was like
you know goku didn't protest and it's
like
serious yeah it's like vegeta didn't
protest they just got it done
and i was like oh my god read the room
man
it was so funny the replies were like
bro it's anime
yeah it's like they're [ __ ]
delusional man
oh my god why what is it like i've
always wanted to know right because i
don't personally know anyone who's in
that fandom
yeah but i've always been interested in
meeting someone irl who's in that fandom
yeah cause i just have someone no no no
no you'll know because they're the
[ __ ] loudest ones yeah
they're the ones in the corner playing
like charging up
trying to be super safe if you ever hear
someone you know who they are
but like i've always just wanted to ask
them being like why
like why why the [ __ ] uh the woman in
the car is like why are you like this
yeah why do you like this like
what like what who conditioned you
to be like i there's so much good anime
out there i'm aware
yes one piece i am aware of that shirt
naruto bleach i'm aware of all these
no goku is my bae and
i will only follow his story it's it's
so weird right because
it's like i i mean what i see in the
shonen fandom is like everything is like
a dick measuring contest
like you you gotta you gotta [ __ ] sim
for your [ __ ] characters and you're
gonna
you're gonna defend them no matter what
like it's
like what i don't understand like i i
guarantee compared to like some of these
dragon ball fans like
dude i i don't even think toriyama is as
big of a dragon ball fan
as [ __ ] dragon ball figures you know
like at least toriyama was like i mean
i've got dragon ball but
i got dragon quest as well you know like
i got all these other things yeah me
while dragon ball fans are like
toriyama god i love you do more dragon
ball
please that's glad i saw me with jojo
yeah
i'm not shouting about it all the time
yeah i'm just like secretly thinking are
you sure about that
all the time not all the time sure about
that gentleman are you sure about that
so when so when connor
i got some i got some [ __ ] to say but no
like sticking with like the dragon ball
and shonen fandom
to me it feels like the [ __ ] ghetto
right because
because the ghetto of the anime
it feels like like constantly having
gang wars with each other and you're
just sitting here watching this like
take place
on twitter
no no no no going into the ghetto
they're just like i don't belong here i
knew you
i'm just watching the hit i'm just
watching this like feud going on on
twitter being like
luffy would beat liv would be [ __ ]
goku in a fight or something like this
yeah
meanwhile one of these fans are like
cool i guess like
i don't i don't [ __ ] care like why
why
why do you care why does why why does
the dragon ball fan base want to give
goku like this amazing kd ratio
i just had this amazing flashback you
remember the time when one punch man
came out yeah like
for some [ __ ] reason there was so
many videos of like
who will win goku yeah yeah and like
if you dare say an opinion it's like get
ready to get [ __ ] destroyed by either
founder
what was even worse than that was uh did
you remember when like death battle did
goku versus superman oh my god and that
got
so toxic that they had to redo it to
give the same results
imagine being like caring that much
about some fictional fan
fight like this is literally like four
riders in the room who are like i think
goku would win
and people are like i can't believe it i
can't make sense of this my
day is ruined do they even watch the
show
you would know if you saw the size of
goku's nipples if there is
no way he would lose in a fight it's not
possible
it's like it's insane it's actually
insane like i i
i don't understand because i've never
cared that much about something in my
life yeah
like i i have been in like university
i've had my youtube channel completely
demonetized that's all my income and i
i care less about that i i mean i care a
lot i was
i didn't want to go broke what's one
thing though about the dragon ball fan
base that
i like i'm pretty sure i'm quite correct
on
and just shocks me is that i guaran
[ __ ] t
that 99 of like hardcore dragon ball
fans probably didn't even watch the
first dragon ball
they started from z that's a
controversial take care i guarantee it's
an assumption joey
you get an assumption but i'm willing to
bet on it every dragon ball fan is now
going to come up and be like uh excuse
me i've watched
i'm gonna say something that is
completely no no basis okay whatsoever
go on i think the dragon ball fans are
one bad day away from being furries
there
no i said it okay i think they are i
think they act in the same way that
furry's doing sometimes you know
i mean i mean isn't it is it goku monkey
i saw that
as somebody who was a very angry child i
know exactly where that anger is coming
from i know where it's coming from you
know it's
about to jump into the pit i'm just
saying man
they they're like one bad forum click
away
that one bad youtube recommendation away
from like falling down in that rabbit
hole
you're [ __ ] destroyed oh my goodness
good thing we're [ __ ] drunk
what do you mean god i have like four
sips
it's gonna the more like the more we
drink i think that my parents
didn't love me as much as the fans love
goku i'll be honest all right
i don't know what that says about my
parents
no your parents loved you fine i'm sure
my parents would not defend me on a
comment section
no very aggressive they'd be like this
is just on you connor
i just imagine now like what if goku was
an actual person and he just saw all
did you think of goku okay has goku
committed war crimes yes
do we know if goku would they defend
goku i mean we know what would happen if
he was hiv positive right
but we don't know what would happen i i
think it's great that
goku is advocating for hiv awareness
i think that's great you know i more
power to them you know i
don't know if that's in the agenda i
have to start a parody series now where
i just go through every shonen
protagonist and just
go into situations if there were
[Laughter]
syphilis off his dick i don't know
i mean okay i love to clown on dragon
ball fans because they are like the
brick wall of opinions yeah yeah it's
like it doesn't matter what you say
it's just like we can't take you
seriously i mean it's because most of
the time they're arguing
a point that can't be like proved anyway
it's all like it's all like
situational because who cares about
power levels because you can't really
argue about power levels
unless you watch death battle you know
and people still disagree with you even
then it's yeah if there's no basis
even if you put science into it people
are gonna like rep this [ __ ] no matter
what you know what exactly
exactly it's like a [ __ ] religion you
know it is a religion yeah it's a cult
it's a cult it's it's the cult of dragon
ball
that's what that's exactly what it is
dragon ball fans watching this be like
[ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] they're all good like i i
it's just
a level of excitement that i've never
felt for or like passion that i've never
felt for anything
i don't know if that means that i'm
lacking in something in my life but then
i see how passionate they are and
yeah i'm kind of glad that i have
hobbies
other than dragon ball
i'm glad i have other things that i can
like put my time in i'm gonna be like go
read gay porn connor yeah yeah yeah
i don't know how many burns can we get
on like one episode yeah
like don't get me wrong like i'm i'm
sure all three of us
love dragon ball right like we grew up
with that [ __ ] of course it's [ __ ]
epic
but we like i know wait no i never grew
up on it
oh you did it no because i i was always
so [ __ ] confused what was happening
oh yeah that's right yeah
how are you confused well i was always
confusing about a kid where i would
watch a fight and then the next episode
was them like talking yeah we talked
about it in the previous episode yeah
yeah
completely out of order that's fair yeah
but i mean like
but i mean you know it is a very
inoffensive show yeah like because it's
hard to
hate dragon ball okay i feel okay like i
love the charm of dragon ball and i love
i love the mainstream
like everyone knows dragon ball yeah and
dude when you're listening to a rap song
and you hear like a dragon ball
reference as an anime fan you're like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah krillin
i don't even know who that is but that's
cool because what i don't understand is
like how
dragon ball is still i guess as loved as
it is
because you know it's got such a huge
like pop and like mainstream yeah
because like i love dragon ball z but my
god i could not watch dragon ball z
today no
it has not aged well at all in terms of
the pacing and everything
and i remember like trying to watch like
the newest dragon balls and
i can't even remember the [ __ ] name
what's the new dragon super dragon ball
super that was it
and i remember trying to watch like an
awkward two and it was just
exactly the same as dragon ball z it was
like
slightly faster it was just cleaner line
art
but like my god like i don't know how
this
how there are still so many passionate
fans whereas like naruto fans they saw
borrowton they're like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i [ __ ] suck yeah
exactly dragon ball fans are here
repping dragon ball super where i think
it's an
okay show you know it and that's like
you're gonna get flames
how dare he was okay it was okay it was
i mean i feel like dragon ball is a
fandom that is just like what the
creators are just like
i guess just give them the same thing
again yeah slightly different goku has
blue hair now is that correct am i am i
saying things yeah
he he's super he can go super saiyan
black now as well yeah is that the
clicker
he's the strongest in the universe now
how can we help me up that up
multiverse yeah let's have a tournament
arc
but we get the lord of each universe to
fight
and then they become i'm pretty sure
that's uh if like
it sounds really [ __ ] cool on paper
yeah but it
it's the reason why i think god of high
school is kind of meh it's like it's
all just like a dick measuring contest
like you said yeah and after a certain
point you're like
damn rent a girlfriend's story is kind
of good though yeah like you know what i
mean like
you kind of just need something more
right right it's more wi-fi
i'm sure the fans would argue it does
but for me it just does it and i'm sorry
dragon ball fans that i'm openly
[ __ ] on you
yeah that's what you're into i get it
dude i'm into stuff
i i like dragon he's not sorry i like i
like dragon ball z
dragon ball was of my [ __ ] childhood
but growing up
i still hold it close to my heart but i
can't watch that [ __ ] you know it's
it's it's i don't have the patience to
go through
what i did as a kid you know but yeah
but that's what i find interesting right
is that like
this kind of super super committed
dragon ball fan base
it doesn't exist in japan there aren't
people today who are like
hyper committed to dragon ball or dragon
ball super or anything dragon ball
related yeah
now here then there are people like in
america and like overseas you don't see
that much
you don't like it's normally like
they'll have a section for it like there
are people like dragon ball here at
least in japan now
is just kind of put in the hall of fame
of like this is an anime that everyone
knows everyone
everybody it's like naruto right yeah
it's like naruto bleach
dragon ball they're all finished series
their tv
anime is finished their manga is
finished they're in the hall of fame
right yeah if you like it
cool you'll hear it in passing but it
isn't like
i have committed my entire life to
wondering
if what would happen if goku was hiv
positive
i need to know you're not gonna get that
here
i just realized the irony of me getting
very defensive about the back of their
job and then just [ __ ] on yeah
literally two minutes later i can i can
get
[ __ ] i hear if you if you like dragon
hypocrite hypocrites hypocrite
hey if you want to defend it that's fine
i just think it's funny to like joke
about
[ __ ] you can [ __ ] on what i like it's
totally fine i don't give a [ __ ]